y
[Música]
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
selenski dice haber visto señales
positivas tras la reunión de este martes
entre representantes de moscú y kiev en
estambul rusia se compromete a reducir
su actividad en torno a kiev la capital
y en chiriquí mientras que la delegación
ucraniana afirmó tener la voluntad para
declararse como un estado neutral
tenemos análisis
occidente recibe los resultados de las
negociaciones con cautela eeuu francia
alemania reino unido e italia abogan por
no bajar la guardia
veremos si cumplen afirmó el presidente
joe biden mientras que el pentágono
advierte que cree que no hay una
retirada de las tropas sean rusas sino
un reposicionamiento
miles de personas se manifestaron en
varias ciudades de haití para protestar
contra la creciente delincuencia y el
control que han tomado las bandas
criminales en los últimos meses puerto
príncipe la capital y los callos fueron
dos de los epicentros de esas
movilizaciones en esta última ciudad la
multitud incendió una avioneta de un
grupo de misioneros de eeuu
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa en la pantalla de france 24
gracias por continuar con nosotros mi
nombre es juan pupiales
comenzamos con el conflicto entre rusia
y ucrania el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski dice haber visto
señales positivas tras el encuentro de
cerca de cuatro horas que delegaciones
de kiev y moscú celebraron en estambul
turquía rusia se comprometió a reducir
radicalmente su actividad alrededor de
kiev y la capital y de chernin he fue
una ciudad al norte del país por su
parte la representación ucraniana afirmó
tener la voluntad de declararse como un
estado neutral algo que frenaría a sus
aspiraciones para unirse a la otan que
es uno de los reclamos de rusia
escuchemos las palabras del presidente
selenski
debate
si podemos decir que las señales que
escuchamos de las conversaciones son
positivas pero estas señales no pueden
silenciar las explosiones de los
proyectiles rusos muy máximos y grace
aquí por supuesto estamos viendo todos
los riesgos por supuesto no vemos
motivos para confiar en las palabras que
vienen de los representantes del país y
sigue luchando para destruirnos sara de
nación es lo decía el propio presidente
selenski hay señales positivas tras
estas negociaciones en estambul para
analizar esta jornada vamos a ir a
buenos aires argentina para hablar con
milena turús ella es analista de
internación internacionalista y
especialista en geopolítica milena
gracias por estar con nosotros milena
vemos que se habla de manera positiva
después de esta ronda de negociaciones
pero por ejemplo hoy en la ciudad de
mykolaiv 12 personas murieron tras un
ataque ruso por lo menos en el terreno
rusia mantiene su ofensiva
con las fueron muchas gracias por la
invitación saludo desde buenos aires son
buenas noticias pero no son las que nos
espera estamos esperando por un alto el
fuego sin embargo esto es lo que sucedió
sin embargo es una buena noticia esta
necesidad de retiro pero no tan así de
las tropas de rociados aunque sean una
una especie de
una paz media extraña porque si bien
ellos dijeron que me iba a ser un actor
fuego la delegación de rusia en mi
dientes y específicamente quienes bajen
el jefe de la delegación de iu
nutricional de rusia en no es un alto el
fuego si bien es una buena noticia que
esperamos que pueda prolongarse y que
efectivamente sea un alto al fuego
eventualmente
milena porque insiste tanto rusia en que
ucrania sea un estado neutral es
solamente para asegurarse por un lado
que quien no entre en la otan o hay algo
más
es específicamente eso lo que se está
buscando rusia es su seguridad
nosotros en relaciones internacionales
de varias corrientes que analizan estos
conflictos
básicamente los estados buscan sobrevida
en el sistema internacional y lo que
está buscando rusia es protegerse ante
esta amenaza de la otan a sus
inseguridades integridad territorial y
lo que ellos persiguen desde moscú no
obviamente
entonces rusia ve a ucrania
específicamente al este como parte de su
propio territorio como parte integral
del territorio de rusia como una
historia en común de una comunidad en
común y por eso decide utilizar la
fuerza armada creo que ya lo habíamos
visto también con actividad en 2014 y
también lo vimos en el 2008 con la
guerra con georgia guerra los 5 días que
tuvimos en su época como la primera
demostración de fuerza rusa después de
la caída del yen soviética pero
básicamente que rusia está buscando
protegerse de esta posible expansión de
la otan y de la influencia de stanford
eeuu como de sus aliados europeos hace
su vecindario hacia su patio trasero
como para decirlo en términos más
comunes
milena porque turquía porque esos ya
luego se están celebrando en estambul
qué papel juega este país
con esta es una pregunta muy interesante
es algo que yo estaba pensando en estos
días
este giro con las negociaciones como
saben se estaban dando el de la luz como
si llegara en el 2015 de los discos
están bien que fueron los nacimiento de
los tratados o los acuerdos de minsk que
putin después de anuncios como que eran
obsoletos que ya no funcionaba
y que después la independencia de las
repúblicas operativas de donets y no gas
que dio inicio también a los sucesos que
estamos viendo ahora entonces porque
turquía porque queríamos a turquía yo
creo que bielorrusia era un estado que
no se veía como tan neutral lado que la
invasión por parte del flanco norte de
ucrania este yo a través del territorio
de la ruso entonces ucrania buscado otra
opción se había hablado de hungría se ha
hablado de otros estados pero finalmente
él pues turquía y yo creo que también
tiene que ver el rol preponderante que
está teniendo turquía en la región en el
cáucaso también el año pasado lo vimos
en el conflicto de nagorno karabaj o la
república zar que se vio involucrado de
una manera muy interesante turquía y
también turquía es bastante cercano a
rusia si bien también es parte de la
otan es como de los más amigables con
rusia dentro de la alianza
se melena muchísimas gracias por este
análisis sobre sus diálogos de los que
venimos hablando las potencias
occidentales seleccionaron con cautela
las conclusiones de hoy en esas con
negociaciones entre rusia y ucrania eeuu
francia alemania reino unido e italia
abogan por que moscú siga pagando el
precio de su intervención militar los
líderes de esas naciones mantuvieron
este martes una conversación telefónica
aseguraron que no puede haber una
distensión en su determinación contra el
horror que vive el pueblo ucraniano por
su parte el pentágono advirtió que cree
que los recientes movimientos de las
tropas rusas pueden no ser una retirada
sino un reposicionamiento
antes de que el rápido avance hacia aquí
en los primeros días de la guerra nos
mostró muy claramente a todos que quiere
la capital de un objetivo clave para los
rusos así que no deberíamos ser
engañados y nadie debería engañarse a sí
mismo por la afirmación reciente del
kremlin de que de repente reducirá los
ataques militares cerca de kiev o
cualquier informe de que va a retirar
todas sus fuerzas
entre tanto amnistía internacional lanzó
su informe anual de derechos humanos se
acusó a rusia de cometer crímenes de
guerra en ucrania le reprochó el consejo
de seguridad de naciones unidas no
actuar adecuadamente frente a las
atrocidades en el país de europa del
este así como en otras naciones como mi
hermano o etiopía por otra parte la ong
deploró la desigualdad mundial en el
acceso a las vacunas contra el kobe 19
una repetición de lo que vimos en síria
así define amnistía internacional la
invasión rusa de ucrania en su último
informe sobre la situación de los
derechos humanos en el mundo la
organización acusó a moscú de crímenes
de guerra
amnistía internacional ha documentado
ataques indiscriminados y muy
probablemente deliberados contra civiles
los corredores humanitarios no funcionan
y la gente que intenta usarlos puede
quedar atrapada la situación es o está
muy cerca de ser de posibles crímenes de
guerra
en su informe la organización pide
reformas dado que las instituciones
multilaterales como el consejo de
seguridad de la onu no han podido evitar
conflictos globales que propiciaron la
invasión rusa de ucrania
francamente hablamos de un consejo de
inseguridad el consejo de seguridad no
ha sido capaz de resolver los conflictos
del mianmar etiopía o israel allanando
el camino para la insolencia de rusia
para su agresión
[Música]
respecto a la gestión del coronavirus en
2021 amnistía habla de una historia de
traición e hipocresía los países ricos
prometieron igualdad de acceso a la
vacuna pero mientras los índices de
vacunación en europa superan el 70 por
ciento algunos estados de rentas bajas
no han recibido ni una dosis
2021 es la mayor traición al pueblo
recuerden en los primeros meses vamos a
reconstruir mejor e hicieron todo lo
contrario pusieron los beneficios de
unas pocas empresas por encima de las
personas entre niveles sin precedentes
de migración en 2021 la ong lamentó las
violaciones de derechos generalizadas y
el aumento de los discursos xenófobos en
el norte global aunque aplaudió el
aumento de la solidaridad por parte de
la socia civil con los desplazados en
otras noticias del presidente de eeuu yo
bailé firmó el convirtió en la primera
legislación federal que convierte el
linchamiento en un crimen de odio bajo
esta normativa se puede procesar
cualquier conspiración de ese tipo que
termine en la muerte de una persona o en
una herida muy grave esta es una ley que
se castigará ahora con 30 años de
prisión fue bautizada bajo el nombre de
e-mail en oro en honor a un joven de 14
años que fue brutalmente asesinado en
misisipí en
este mar de aceite vivió una jornada de
manifestaciones en contra de la
violencia y la delincuencia que están
disparadas en la nación caribeña a pesar
de que las manifestaciones
transcurrieron con calma en los cayos un
grupo de manifestantes incendió una
avioneta y al menos uno de ellos murió
tras recibir un disparo de la policía
como síntoma del descontento
generalizado miles de haitianos salieron
a las calles del país para protestar en
contra de la creciente inseguridad y los
secuestros en la nación caribeña
las autoridades están ausentes así que
nosotros siendo abogados decidimos
marchar para expresar que estamos hartos
de que pasen estas cosas
numerosas ongs y grupos de la sociedad
civil convocaron la marcha en contra de
la inacción del gobierno contra las
bandas criminales que controlan gran
parte de puerto príncipe la capital
muchos señalan directamente al primer
ministro ariel en río por su mala
gestión
estamos acá para exigir ariel enrique al
director general de la policía que hagan
todo lo posible para garantizar la
seguridad del pueblo o dimitan a pesar
de que las manifestaciones
transcurrieron con calma en la capital
en los cayos al suroeste del país un
grupo de manifestantes prendió fuego al
avión de unos misioneros estadounidenses
país al que acusan de injerencia acción
rechazada por el gobierno
condeno enérgicamente la violencia de
los manifestantes que resultó en el
incendio de un avión en el aeropuerto de
los cayos he dado instrucciones a las
autoridades públicas para que pongan en
marcha acciones contra los autores de
estos actos subversivos para que sean
severamente sancionados
esta es la mayor movilización en haití
desde el magnicidio del antiguo
presidente joven el mois en julio de
2021 y coincide con el 35 aniversario de
la constitución del país que lleva
registrando niveles de violencia y
delincuencia
alarmantes desde la muerte de moix cinco
personas perdieron la vida en medio de
un tiroteo no suburbio ultraortodoxo de
la ciudad de tel aviv en israel la
policía mató al atacante quien sería de
origen árabe israelí desde jerusalén
nuestra corresponsal de amira gómez
muñoz tiene los detalles
tercer atentado terrorista en israel en
tan solo una semana tras los ataques con
cuchillo y arma de fuego en ver chivas y
jáder a la periferia de tel aviv ha sido
el escenario de un nuevo tiroteo con
cinco víctimas mortales en esta ocasión
un motorista armado de un fusil m-16 fue
quien disparó a transeúnte y vecinos de
las ciudades de vena y vrac y ramat gan
dicho atacante que también murió en la
escena fue identificado como un joven
palestino de cisjordania algo que éste
distingue de los otros autores árabes
israelíes simpatizantes del estado
islámico con un total de 11 personas
muertas en siete días los más
sangrientos desde el año 2006 el primer
ministro naftalí bennett declaró que
israel se enfrenta a una ola mortal de
terrorismo árabe contra la cual prometió
luchar con mano de hierro un mensaje que
está lejos de calmar las tensiones en
vísperas de abril mes que ya inquietaba
por la coincidencia del ramadán la
semana santa cristiana y la pascua judía
muestra del temor a una nueva espiral de
violencia son las reacciones a este
atentado por ejemplo celebrado por hamas
y la jihad islámica a la vez que
repudiado por los ultraortodoxos de pene
y vrac al grito de muerte a los árabes
en medio en un gesto poco común el
presidente palestino mahmud abás condenó
la matanza diciendo que conduce a un
deterioro de la situación ante este
escenario la policía israelí ya ha
decretado el nivel de alerta máximo
su más recientes redadas en barrios
árabes y ensayos de alarmas antiaéreas
por su parte benet liderará este
miércoles un gabinete de seguridad en el
que revisará el actual plan de
contención y edad pinkett smith se
pronunció por primera vez tras el
incidente de crisis rock y sus posibles
meses durante la ceremonia de los
premios oscar la actriz escribió en su
cuenta de instagram en un escueto es
tiempo de sanar ya estoy lista para ello
dando así por terminada la polémica que
generó la bofetada que le propinó su
pareja al humorista la agresión se dio
después de que roca bromeara sobre la
alopecia de lleida durante la
transmisión
este martes a las 8 y 15 de la noche
hora de bogotá quito y lima viva con
nosotros el desenlace y análisis de la
última jornada de las eliminatorias
suramericanas al mundial de qatar-2022
durante media hora hablaremos de la
definición de la quinta plaza que da
acceso al repechaje para la copa mundo y
de todas las selecciones con su pasaje
acá para acatar lo presenta nuestro
compañero rodrigo ciudadano
así terminamos este informativo que
desde nuestra pantalla
[Música]